hello and welcome to carnegie mellon
university's new academic year I'm subra
Suresh and I'm delighted to join you as
the ninth president of CMU my wife Mary
and I have been pleased to receive many
good wishes since our arrival so let me
begin by saying thank you for making us
feel so welcome I especially want to
greet students and families who are just
like me new to see and you you will find
that Carnegie Mellon is an unusual and
impressive place and that is because of
the remarkable and talented people in
the university community worldwide CMU's
record of contribution across
disciplines makes us a destination of
choice for talented students and faculty
from all over the world we work
creatively on the most pressing problems
of our time and our aspirations to do
this continues to grow I'm also engaged
in a listening tour of the University I
will be meeting with students faculty
staff and alumni on campus and at many
locations across the US and around the
world I encourage everyone who wants to
contribute to this deliberative process
to do so either at one of these
gatherings or through the CMU leadership
website once again welcome
and best wishes to you for a productive
and successful academic here I look
forward to working with you as we take
this great University to even greater
heights thank you
you